بعد بعد حماه والمدرسه وحكايتك مع الوالد
طبعا نتائج دمشق الى المعهد يعني
وادي محطه اساسيه في تكوينك الاكاديمي
بدنا نقوله وكيف تتعامل مع الالوان ومع
وفي اساتذه لابد انه ساهموا في في
صقلتك مين الاساتذه اللي اللي كان قال له
فعلا دور في تحريك شيء في ذاتك هلا فتره
دمشق كانت كثير كثير مهمه انه
فرغتني لحلمي يعني صرت متفرغ 24 ساعه
حلو وتاريخ الفن وفلسفه الفن وعلم الجمال
وبلشنا نطلع على شغل اساتسنا كان استاذي
مثلا زياد استاذنازير نبع استاذ استاذ
محمود حماد استاذتي
كان فتره رائعه يعني من التفرغ
ودراسه التكنيك ودراسه الفن التشكيلي
بسوريا وبالعالم يعني مكتب الي كانت
موجوده بالكليه
ومكاتب دمشق غير المكتبات تبع حماه يعني
كانت اغنى واثره يعني اي مكان
[موسيقى]
لاول مره يمكن بشوف لوحه حقيقيه منصوره
معارض الفنانين تشكيليين واسادسي كان في
معرض كثير بهديك الفتره نتعرف على
الفنانين على المدارس
[موسيقى]
76 كان كل سنه اولى ثاني
مركز ثقافي العربيه
كان بيضم اكثر من 70 عمل مشغولين بالزيتي